As we race towards more sophisticated
forms of virtual reality,
it's worth considering the work of
Stanley Kubrick who spent his career
probing and solving the questions of
immersive storytelling in ways that
still remain unique more than any other
director.
It's easy to imagine Kubrick's films as
worlds that we could explore as games or
even virtual reality rides where we've
glide through narrative spaces intensely
involved,
but never in control.
This is because cooper was as much
concerned with the way audiences engaged
with his movies as he was with the ideas
that they were trying to convey.
In fact,
for Kubrick,
these two things were inseparably
linked.
We often think of Cooper as a highly
stylized director,
which he was a crucially.
Kubrick never lets us forget what the
purpose of style actually is.
Style is a lens that gives the viewer a
point of access to the material.
It's about the audience,
not the director.
Something that new filmmakers should
keep in mind.
Today,
I want to take a closer look at eyes
wide shut Kubrick's final film and the
ways it immerses us in the story of
Alice and especially Dr.
Bill Hartford,
a married couple going through a
difficult time in their relationship,
and this isn't the first film to deal
with subjects of love or sex infidelity
or even secret colts,
but Kubrick is intent on making our
engagement with these things.
One of a kind.
How does he do that?
Well,
the first and most noticeable aspect of
eyes wide shut is definitely it's
strange pacing.
It's a slow moving on the level of
narrative,
but especially in the dialogue.
Listening to Tom Cruise and Nicole
Kidman speak is like watching a dripping
faucet.
Every word drops out of their mouths
with the same lifeless rhythm.
Look,
women don't.
They basically just don't think like
that.
If you see exhaustion in their faces and
hear it in their voices,
that's because they really were
exhausted.
Kubrick made his actors to countless
takes of every scene,
including the ones where they had to
break down and cry.
This is the reason why eyes wide shut
holds the Guinness record for the
longest movie shoot ever,
but it's also the reason for these
utterly unique performances.
Something beyond tired.
Beyond Giddy,
that state of Dreamy Detachment Kubrick
was going for,
and
now this accomplishes two things.
First,
it adds to the hypnotic tone of the
film.
Eyes wide shut is based a novella called
dream story,
and the film certainly plays out like a
dream or drugged up hallucination and
second,
the detached performances serve to block
the lead characters from being targets
of the viewers.
Empathy,
that makes for a really interesting
combination.
Let me explain why from the moment bill
leaves the house after Alice gives a
long wounding speech about her fantasy
of sleeping with another man.
The narrative conspires across a series
of increasingly sexualized encounters to
deeply involve you in the unfolding
events.
First,
the patient's daughter confesses her
love to bill.
Then bill hires a prostitute.
Then bill meets an old friend at a cafe
who tells him about a secret sex party
later that night,
then at a costume shop after hours,
bill witnesses the owners,
young daughter sleeping with two
businessmen,
and finally bill arrives at the sex
part,
which is much more intense than he
anticipated.
All this time you're experiencing the
night from the perspective of bill,
but not from a position of empathy or
even sympathy for that matter.
Instead,
the viewer engages in what philosopher
Alessandra Anelli calls experiential
identification in which the result of
occupying bill's perspective,
while not empathizing with him is that
the perspective becomes your own.
It's really as if the viewer is playing
a virtual reality game of eyes wide
shut.
This explains why we react to the orgy
sequence with such intensity,
cooper leads us down beat by beat to
this moment with precision.
We've been pulled so far into the dream
that the simple act of bill putting on
his mask or racing his identity
completely is for the viewer a moment of
deeper immersion.
Then the best vr
from that moment on the experience of
the party is as much ours as it is,
bills.
There are plenty of things that Kubrick
does visually here to draw you in as he
does in his other movies,
like using wide angle lenses or
switching to pov shots.
Most of which are unfortunately too
explicit for me to show.
But what sets eyes wide shut apart is
this systematic effort to swap you in
for the protagonist.
This is what the whole movie visuals,
narrative,
dialogue and character works together to
accomplish the masked ball orgy scene
takes place exactly halfway through the
movie,
but you're captured in its world for the
remaining hour.
What exactly happened?
How did you let yourself get in so deep?
You're questions are the same as bills,
and as the two of you attempt to piece
together,
the answer is like a dream.
Half remembered.
Nothing comes up,
clear bill can't reach his patient's
starter.
He can't find his friend,
Nick Knight and and when he goes back to
the home of the prostitute,
she's gone.
Even at the costume shop,
things have completely changed.
Nothing quite make sense.
You were going to call the police.
Whoa.
Things change.
The information that you can piece
together tells a story that's dark and
haunting.
I noticed Mr.
Nightingale had a bruise on his cheek
and to be perfectly honest,
I also thought you looked a bit scared.
Then at the end,
Sydney Pollack suddenly appears again
mirroring his appearance at the
beginning of the film as an
authoritative voice to offer an
explanation that paints a more innocent
picture.
You just might.
I have the wrong idea.
By the one or two things,
you know,
Cooper died only a few days after
completing the final edit of eyes wide
shut.
By that time in his career,
a lot of people had written and said a
lot of things about his work.
People are still doing it.
I'm doing it right now,
but the viewer is who cooper cared about
most and he or she stands were bill.
Hartford stands in between the artist's
intention,
critics,
interpretation,
and the actual experience of the movie
itself.
Eyes Wide Shut,
I think is an ode to the experience,
to the raw impression of seeing
something marvelous Kubrick drags you
into the movie plants you edit center
and challenges you to figure out what
happened.
He was a stylist,
but his style was for us.
He made some of the best movies of all
time.
More importantly,
he taught us how to watch them.
Everybody,
thank you so much for your time
during this episode was brought to you
by squarespace.
If you want to make a website,
you want it to be a really easy process.
Squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes the process really simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to insult,
no patches ever,
and being your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Really simple way to make a website.
Thanks guys.
I'll see the rest of you next Wednesday.